the seasonal doesn't really matter and
we'll show you guys where this event is
I'm pretty sure the butchers in this so
there's a bunch of cool stuff there's
like did you play a lot of the hablo one
no okay so I'll be calling out to some
of the stuff that wasn't in Diablo 1
like they have like these certain like
armor and stuff like that that you would
find that's like godly armor of whale
and that was the stuff people used to
dupe a lot and like you could go into
games and get duped items all right so
we got one that said barbarian barbarian
I'm gonna give it like 30 more seconds
what is your favorite Lassie Diablo 3
monk by far I have played a thousand
hours I think a monk
personal preference necro would be kind
of fitting in in in some ways actually
not that's not true there was no necro
in d1 there's only in DC Reapers
alright we're tired I guess the next one
pushes it over the edge or you can vote
and I will go with whatever what if
someone else says like oh wait a monk
and a necro there so that's for necros
warnekros rhubarb's for Nick yeah okay
Nick over for barbarians for barbarians
but that's the same guy why are they
super boring play the necro alright
necro it is a female or male mic I think
mine is a
so okay what would you like to name it
necro all right without the capsule oops
oh just lower case sure all right here
we go
necro yeah we know permanent death all
right so I'm gonna make it I'll change
it to hard I'm not going to expert since
it is a I got to get to the portal it's
not to posit in it's not too far it's
very closer to your like it's very close
let's get past this farthest you've
gotten in hardcore before oh man I don't
know actually I never really tried to go
hard Oh
act he was really tough though I had a
monk so my resistant to doing way up is
the month sorry I did not have a monk I
had a wizard so yeah so my intelligence
is way out so my resistance to all those
elemental effects yeah you got to play
really defensive in hardcore and like
slow level two feels good
you got bone spear I played a necro
through to level 70 in like a day or two
yeah I felt like it was ope a little bit
but yeah it's it's pretty decent at like
when you just like to start you know so
that corpse explodes pretty good yeah we
just gotta get through this part alright
yeah they're all zombies we get it
someone was asking stooge I was asking
on YouTube does this work on console 2
or is this just on PC I can't remember
actually he'll look it up I gotta go
talk to Rumford apologies I figured it
would be more fun to start making a
character and hardcore and all that and
maybe in hindsight I should have just
got us to where we were supposed to be
but this is the only good feeling about
starting a new character Mike is
equipping anything you find any white
object yeah I think we're not too far
though I think it's like right past this
this area if I recall correctly yeah
because this is nutrition ready too much
if we don't finish the objective I hope
we'll see it ends on January 30th yep
started the first I believe right yeah
this was a couple days ago they don't I
was reading battlenet didn't also I
think someone asked earlier if this is
offline or online it has to be online
because the battlenet just always online
now so unfortunately that is just the
case yeah believe it's consoles go maybe
someone in check and maybe someone in
check and tell us what's up so thanks
everyone for tuning in we appreciate it
we are live every day at 11 a.m. the
lobby if you guys didn't know is just
currently on a little mini hiatus as we
kind of update and upgrade the studio so
I have more word on that coming soon
mike is the host of the lobby for those
that didn't know that was a pretty good
2017
yeah kind of continued the experiment
dimension of a lot but all right so if
you didn't know if you just go to the
old ruins you'll be able to access this
new area you don't have to make a new
character to access a new area you can
technically just use a previous
character that you had it doesn't matter
if it's seasonal or whatever doesn't
matter
Tyrel would I'm on the ps4 in its day
that's weird it's a post right here
alright hold on is it no you know what I
okay hold on I'm a dummy I think someone
just said aren't you supposed to get
there as a level 1 character and not
level up you can do that I screwed up I
did story instead of Adventure mode and
I think if I did a venture mode it would
have been fine and it would have been
there so in theory I could make another
character but I'm not going to do that
that's fine you only got level 4 3 can
you play the entire game of this
seasonal character well yes your
seasonal character will never get
deleted it just will fall out of that
season so it's like here you go see
sorry so it shows up as the dark new
mutation 16 of the original I it's not
this it's not that there are original
levels as much as the the layer itself
or the dungeon it's like 16 levels deep
so this is what it looks like
super pixelated and the walking is like
the way it used to be the ex yeah the
kind of like directions and we'll head
towards like the Cathedral where like
you know where school coach supposed to
slay the Dark Lord which he should be on
the 16th floor
assuming we make it our character is
hardcore speaking on console now what
are how this would feel to walk around
with those four directions on counsel do
you think or do you think that it's
differ
council yeah I have no idea I haven't
tried it on console like every 60
rotation like the rest yeah whoever in
chat earlier that said that they play or
are playing on console I guess they
could kind of speak to that experience
this is like things got the hold music
yeah as mentioned it's a pretty good
starter class yeah also there are
rewards you can get like I think there's
like a butcher pet and like making the
portrait so there is kind of reason to
do it I suppose I would say a little
dried up I mean like seasonal stuff is
like armor sets or whatever but for the
most part I don't think there's as much
interest I for me personally I think I
want to be able to easily make more than
anything but I don't know if we'll ever
get that I kind of thought they would do
that you know when they announced the
20th anniversary and then I thought
maybe like last year but then they kind
of stalled just felt out a little bit
with necro as like felt like it was like
buying time you know
w SiC Diablo character class
[Applause]
like an elf no because like I love it
whoa some other stuff this wouldn't make
too much sense like if you had on terms
that they're gonna add in an extra or
they sorry they already someone can
correct I'm sure somebody will correct
having plates in college but I I lost a
lot of time to back that said it's
butcher pet and there's a rare cow so
far this hasn't been too bad on hard
hardcore oh so I think this is uh this
is a callback right here
Kings sword of haste this is like
something that they used to have back in
the day that you would just I like that
you wanted to carrot the weapon portrait
actually looks low res to it yeah it's
just for these older weapons I think oh
and they're straight up and down as
opposed to that so there's this some
callbacks for those we will play
the other one actually was you want to
say like one of the helmets a few games
okay I was lucky enough that my husband
had two older and using the card he's
like dude you should try this game I
okay he got me on oh there's a butcher
[Music]
but on that note you can see that the UI
see the health mana
I know but like I could
[Music]
nor do my potions uncle always do they
didn't have that back in the daylight
all right the game do you have all
heroes
I thought it was really good yeah I like
that um one of the things it does that
like I use how the Bob games there's
like you know like you had that one
friend I'm like and like this prevent
you from moving forward but in Diablo
and we were just teleport everyone into
like that person like whoever's like
farthest which I liked a lot doesn't
like me I don't know I guess you could
argue that to stop people from exploring
what that help save
press the keypad and he'll say you don't
have to go in inventory and stop
everybody from playing you could just
equip them on the fly I like that it was
a good workaround I just oh yeah that
was annoying that definitely was
annoying I remember but I do there's
some things that are in console that I
feel like are better than they are on
PCs you could trade or that the role
there's like almost like just enough one
no overwatch is like starting
start on lemonade
we're going down
[Music]
this is this is like old school like how
it looked like - in terms of like the
icon and godly weight of the place like
godly anything of the any sailing was
like so good like we've actually really
satisfying the deep stuff in Diablo like
you you used to have to so like they had
spell books and things like that yeah
and like armor right so you would throw
the armor on the ground essentially and
then you take like a potion and if you
could walk like you would walk up to it
and throw the potion out at the same
time you picked it up it would do pit
yeah I just
people are saying the game volume with
drowning so is that better everybody let
me know if I turn out louder
I turned down I turned up our our volume
is turned down the game going you can
max this out and still have the game
ball really high I did okay hopefully
it's better now let me know yeah so yeah
I think it's cool to have something like
this you know like you just kind of play
it and cool you're done you know like I
just got a transmog for the butcher's
cleaver which is you know then you can
have that for any of your other stuff
down the road and then you didn't get
the butcher pet or the cow pet then this
would be the time to kind of get back
and I think even Blizzard themselves as
like if you want to experience this in
like one of the best ways to experience
this would be to just make a new
character and kind of go through it yeah
which is what we're doing here haven't
had too many scares and in terms of
dying I'm sure at some point I'm
probably gonna regret that
oh we hang lyrics tune that's from three
right
well yeah I think if you're looking for
an ERP GE I mean Diablo does get updated
like on a decent basis but if you're
looking for oh there's a skeleton king
if you're looking for an A RPG that's
updated kind of more regularly than
Yahoo I would say the Bell is a good
shout yeah and that has like what 12
updates now like Bagon is so many hangs
on console now oh oh god my character
screamed and I thought I
but I didn't do you miss the auction
house ever uh I personally do because
like I thought it was cool I'm like have
fun with my buddy like seeing which like
me and him used to bring her I used to
bring my Mac over to his house to my
laptop when I had this on Mac as well I
had this on PC Mac I played it on my Mac
as well with him and I brought it over
and we would see like whether our bill
sold
yeah or bought anything I don't know I
liked it but I could see why people
didn't it's weird though because I feel
like it was something that a lot of
people kind of wanted from in Diablo 2
also because a lot of people were just
selling hacked items so it was probably
like wizards way of like saying well if
they're gonna make money off of us we
might as well get some of that maybe
yeah I didn't mind it though personally
the game was a lot harder back then to
so in some ways you could say you know
like if you could find a way to make it
easier because you don't have as much
time to spend then you can spend the
money if you didn't want to you know
like I never found anything worthwhile
in the game really it was all through
the auction house do you mean Julio did
came the one was asking what is path of
exile and is it co-op
yeah it's pretty much a action RPG
free-to-play you must be the best way to
scratch your Diablo sewage right now I'd
say yeah that's true yeah because it's
got darker tones and it's got way more
custom it's always daunting in some ways
like how big the story is because it's
just got so much more customized
Wittering this word I've been pretending
it's in the winter break how do you say
customizability yeah that's wrong
ability customization customization I
just say that just customization alright
customization there's so much
customization with the skills that if
you looked at the skill tree is kind of
like holy crap it's like he's going web
yeah
but once you kind of get used to it it's
not too bad and there's room for error
because there's like things that allow
you to Reese kill so it's not like the
end of the world but it is co-op if you
know you want to play with other players
that are in the world game the one was
saying it's free and on console it's
free it's only on PC I believe no it's
on console I don't know if it's free on
console I know it's free for PC though
I'd have to double-check it's free for
college it's if you've been playing a
lot of Diablo 3 it's really daunting of
how you see this ring
yeah it's flickering a little bit I know
it was a trade off I guess it I guess it
works through Diablo 1 this is playable
come on come on double-o seven until
january 30th 2018 and presumably they'll
bring back something similar next year
although like hopefully they've
hopefully by that point they've
announced Diablo 2 remake or Diablo 4 or
whatever they might do yeah what is it
like they've done Starcraft remastered
if they do a table for before Starcraft
three right yes I would have to imagine
that like overwatch there shows no signs
of slowing down still I got thirty
million players
three on Xbox one thanks on your mom
says thank you spawn on your mom so
we're on the third level we plot the
butcher and the skeleton killing
essentially ever those just joining
someone was mentioning uh LVAD this is
Diablo 3 it is the dark name of Tristram
Diablo anniversary event Diablo 1
throwback of 16 levels and the mists
throwback dungeon as noted by this
isometric looking old-school graphics
yep
- there's like I don't know I was
playing earlier on just like a level of
character and there was definitely some
other like callbacks like bosses and
stuff like that I'll try to get through
the dungeon maybe faster
yeah paradise decay was saying I was
actually wondering is there any people
have played that last year this event
and gotten everything is there any
reason to play this again I don't know
if there's anything new now thank you
maybe the portrait cow in the butcher
murder or it would be like a time to get
anything that you may have miss because
I could have easily had just like I
played the event last year and I didn't
have that butcher I must not have ran
into the butcher you know yeah so you
could have missed something if you were
just not careful yeah so it would be
that I think like making sure you have
all that stuff if you didn't get the
first time okay but if he's gotten
everything then to much that person to
do it's not spill I don't remember
please die I can look at chat because
he's got so much life
snot spill yeah there's what happens
when you're like kind of lower level
here I suppose we could trade offs
through that Oh Harlequins chorus crest
is also like a throwback and epochal
this dude there was a spell called
apocalypse in the other one it was so
good last attic the was I think any
class could have any skill as long as
you have this spell book but it was so
good like you would do this huge AoE
that would hit like anything that was on
the spoon which is like pretty insane it
is called apocalypse yeah iron oh gotta
always feels good to get a shiny don't
don't mind me while we quickly put on
some pox balls big Jack was asking he
just said he just started a necromancer
what do you think in the class I think
it's pretty solid it can do high torment
levels if you have the right build and
the right armor set if we have enough
time and if for some reason people are
bored of this I can play my glass cannon
like corpse explode build but we'll see
if how long it was it felt oaky to me
but I don't know if I played on torment
at all yeah it it gets kind of dicey
depending on like the build there's some
that are like more durable but you just
kinda it's a little bit more boring
because you don't do as much but uh yeah
it just depends I think there's a couple
viable builds I know of one that's like
can do really high like greater rifts I
think the the neck OPAC went on sale
like recently feel like 10 bucks
people are saying they're saying oh yeah
there's weird flicker in the black yeah
I see the flickering I can try to fix
that my fear is that no connection if I
do it it might break it again like it
did just now yeah so I not I'll have to
look into that today I just it's risky
you know that's risky
nettie oh wait this event goes until
January 30th and it's on ps4 and Xbox
one bachelor beauty probably if I'm
looking at
yeah because the only option I have is
to switch it back to that other caption
thing which basically Bork to the
computer is it a newer Golic no it
wasn't godly wasn't that godly oh yeah
bezler yes
having exiles on ps4 I believe is it you
said you said console I said console
yeah I did say console I know it's on
Xbox because I actually it would be my
fault if I got if we got that wrong I
know it's on on Xbox for sure not sure
oh I don't know what the hell I just
opened what it gave me an old-school
ring that's cool the Imperium man
it might not be on ps4 Mike's checking
that now apologies if I always encourage
on master it's like I know for sure pub
G is in on ps4 yeah
so I guess not ps4 okay not yet on PC
and the game was released in October
August of this year on Xbox one I don't
know paradise decay if I have the pen I
would have to look I might not have it I
don't remember I think I have the
butcher pepper I have to fire more
toughness sure I'm gonna change this to
like skeletons or something more useful
whoa what happened my bone spear oh I
just don't have s it what a new I
haven't been upgrading our stuff
I was playing [ __ ] to that whole time
path of Exile is not on ps4 cane the one
I think I believe Charles Harvey is
talking about the darkening of Tristram
available but that's next I was
definitely not on ps4 thanks Mike for
the clarification
come on six of 16 we're gonna make it
maybe
or die trying I guess wow that did like
nothing yeah like I blew up like at
least five bodies on that guy when
you're next Knievel today I'll shoot
okay I better fix it by today though I
mean whenever well no I got it I gotta
fix it if you guys are doing this we can
do it tomorrow we'll see I'll test it
after this what oh I had to read the
book to open a door too I want to go I'm
gonna pass on the chamber of bone people
are saying path of Exile is my ps4 they
just bought it I'm fairly are you gained
trolled yeah
it's not shoot do I have to go down
there
that can't be right because it's been
like floors where we're gonna keep
exploring it sucks to not have boots
keys and because this is a new seasonal
character I don't have paragon points
either so I can't add movement speed
which is kind of a bummer that would
look weird with these graphics like the
movie no it would just be like
marginally faster I mean like it's not
like three three is just like so much
smoother obviously looking than this
kind of yeah baby I have to go that way
what do you think down into that the
chamber of bone yeah I would assume I'm
not sold
okay am i sold not sold yet unless I hit
a dead end here which I
don't know wow there's a lot more map
because words like bugs I'm not sure I
have not found words leg in this
playthrough yet though I am trying to
get to the next level 7 min but this
labyrinth is what's on the 16th level I
believe Diablo like Diablo 1 Diablo
because I think there's a gem too that
you can get from this which is like the
hellfire gem which is it makes you look
like what you look like as the warrior
and whoever you'd eat it with and the
other one cuz like you sticks the gem in
his head right and you've gone this
Diablo Diablo to you cuz you can't
control it after a while but yeah you
get that as a thing and like one of the
effects is that like spiraling a fire
that the that Diablo shoots out right so
you get that as an effect with the drum
which is pretty cool
roll next both go back this whole thing
resplendent yeah spear it's got to be
better right all right oh wait it was
yeah it is a spear that looks like a
dagger at the top of the spear I think
yeah well it does more damage so we're
using it way I've never seen this thing
before
if thorns is fear of gyro yeah I've
never seen that before but sure we don't
have iron golem where it would be better
for thorns so what else have what else
did you play during the break now that a
lot switch games or Zelda
keep talking and nobody explodes oh
really manly did you do the r version or
just like no I want to okay but now my
family I feel like that's more tense
what I recall it's like I see this I see
that
oh it's Nightwing here's how like
obviously you have to talk to the person
who is defusing the bomb I wonder if
would they have to do one ear headphones
on one ear and off on the other or
something I guess so
sorry I'm just emptying this just
dropped the spear for a second yeah I
don't I don't it's too good yep yep to
the chamber of bones but keep nah
see I tried to trick me I didn't have to
go to the chamber bones do this is way
darker than most of the rest of this
game
and it's these stupid plague guys
poisoning is gone for now oh really
because it's so dark probably no no it's
actually gone oh really yeah
something-something righted itself
magically works sweet I'll take it I'm
not gonna jinx it alright level up
without doing anything that's the power
of pets and the necro do you remember
how bad the neck like you hate like I
hated playing with neck roads in Diablo
2 because like internet was just so poor
back then I didn't just knock Bob we
just flag the whole screen do you like a
witch doctor in this game oh it's one of
my least played it was I I eventually
won season played in and I thought it
was fine I feel like you need to have
very specific films for that I liked it
but like especially like under level 30
they're not that fun once you get higher
level they're fun yeah I I've always
played combat type characters not really
intelligence types characters so Wizards
a lot did we just come only for the
resplendent chests that suck it didn't
even give me a why that's just where you
go is just I think the rest of this is
just for the blind though we're in the
blind like we are literally it is
telling us how dark this room is oh my
god yep we were supposed to go down to
the chamber of bone sorry chat they just
they wanted you to keep exploring
alright that's fine that's very this is
pretty cool though I like this because
like I want to say in Diablo they had
like
items that actually added light to your
like character later on yeah like it
would give you more it would like kind
of reveal more like fog or darkness
so it actually mattered a little bit in
certain cases but then you know new
Diablo 3 like every you can see
everything yeah that's right like except
for some of the caves but even then it's
not that big of a deal
Eric don't listen to nobody that XP I
wish I could just like teleport back to
the history all those blues I threw
those out they're useless that was not
worth in my Flynn we got played okay you
got the spear though right now I got the
spear from the other I got it I got it I
wait no you're right it was from this
way all right well we didn't need to go
all the way down there what's up Wade
oops you guys and your beards that I
came for oh I just hear rustling
sorry that's our key B yawning I woke up
from that earthquake I like 2/3 oh yeah
I felt it too and like I was kind of
waiting to see if he would get bigger
and then he just kind of stopped I woke
up for the last second of it and felt it
oh really
it kind of felt like a tidal wave or
well that's not true it started off
really small and I was like oh that kind
of feels like an earthquake and then all
of a sudden look like bigger rift came
how's that oh that's an earthquake but
then nothing there's no like aftershock
or anything like that so which is weird
because like we've been do for like a
big one right for like the longest time
which is still kind of nerve-wracking
because we haven't had a big one
you when did you move to California
years ago okay so you didn't feel the
one in 89 that was like a seven point
something that one was big that one was
like scary cuz like you know like I
would crawl into the table as a kid and
like you just hear all this stuff in
like the cab and it's like falling over
and like throw to a doorframe to if you
can't get the table
anything yeah stupid I went into the
under the table and I was like cool I'm
safe and then I look above me and
there's just a bunch of like screws
hanging from the table and I'm like oh
maybe this wasn't the best choice I
thought I'd show the living to collapse
right
yeah I'm like a little child that
probably like has [ __ ] balance and I'm
probably gonna just oh wow there's a lot
of geyser love in the density like oh
they'll they'll explode I meant like oh
you mean on the environment
do I not have one ability that makes me
walk faster
really dude stop sorry about that guys
I'm gonna have to look into that because
that is definitely a problem so is the
other thing in place back in my day
discussion yeah back when I was a wee
lad [ __ ] I love what you asked when I
moved to California knowing full well
that I would not I wasn't even alive in
89
let alone in California were you like
there's nothing here I got tricked again
by you guys
no no that's all yeah [ __ ] all right so
where the hell are we supposed to go if
we started here what's up labyrinth 5
labyrinth 7 so we were in labyrinth 7
but then that led to nothing
something fishy's going on I probably
missed something there's a good chance I
missed something was there not like a
book you had to read in chamber I read
the everybody seemed ready to go a
chamber of bone I think they just wanted
me to go into the chamber bone all right
well that is technically the door to the
next level so we were on the right path
but unless I'm mistaken I didn't see
another door there and there is
definitely 6 levels in the industry
I don't recall picking that up
do you have Ottawa clip on I do but I
had a shield on I know whatever I'm less
than just being the pro player that I am
Nick instinctive we just did it really
quick I remember that there was
something in the chamber ha ha ha what
did you get anything no it wasn't you
know resplendent all right Oh son Oh
Abby is it right there
I played Diablo 2 so much back then that
like they only had X amount of tile sets
for like if you're farming a certain
boss that like I could tell like I gotta
go left yeah like I didn't even need a
map pack anymore he said map pack
because it was just a pain in the butt
you said you didn't play that much
diablo 2 right i played a lot of diablo
2 not 102
sweet yeah like I wish they brought ruin
words back that was like one of the
funnest things I feel like was in that
game what's the closest thing to have
now like Rick's now rude words were
those armor and weapon that you made
like think there's anything in the
course that close as a new player do you
get more lore in this event uh a little
bit it's it has a lot more of they like
callback stuff so like I mean you'll
appreciate it but probably not as much
as if you had played the old stuff
Kenneth Ruby loba was asking do you
still pay for the necro yeah that's
still what if he knows all right I think
this on sale for 10 reason
oh yeah that's not like I'm free with
this update I think you can play this
without the neck you have to play if you
want to play neck or yourself to buy him
yes that's good if you even if you have
the expansion neck are still separate
from a repro soil which although they're
probably a full edition now right like
you could buy still a gripe for me in
the sense that like when we got the
crusader we got a whole new like area
and you cannot get a whole new area when
we got the next round I'll just say that
[Music]
she's kind of a not what's it called
what's the new area called the town
westmarch Westmark yeah yeah like you
got West March with the Crusader but no
we just got a character but it was cheap
arguably I think I can't remember what
their soul is like all in all hobo
Reaper of souls was just like a taking
king type expansion this is just like a
character pack and I don't think the
funny thing was they didn't even start
the season when the neck open now
with your souls add adventure mode where
was that before that no it had a venture
motor ad I think or way no I think
you're right yeah I think you're right
that was God I forgot my time on dude
it's been so long
Douglas James oh there's a first time
for her in the stream in 2018 I didn't
see her on the destiny stream on Tuesday
Tuesday's may learn to enjoy them what's
the next game you're looking forward to
shadow Colossus remake on ps4 Wednesday
February 6
oh no sorry buddy okay there's not much
going on this first quarter as opposed
to last year which is crazy with neo
near horizon was right at the end of it
yeah zo7 yeah did I say me already you
know yeah that was complete edition
though right what oh oh sorry sorry
sorry I started talking about end oh no
beginning of yeah it was uh as opposed
to the 20 there's a pretty packed early
2017 we started off strong that's for
sure or well the industry started off
strong I suppose look at the map more
Mike I don't know man we got eight more
levels I don't know if we're getting
there before what like 12:30 but yeah of
course 4:30
I'd have to here let's just make a
conscious effort to run by a monster
hunter world's on its way yep that's
gonna be a pretty needy game I think you
play a lot of monster nope I think I
might try it out with this one yeah I
don't know why I don't know it's just
because it's on PlayStation that like
I'm like oh you know like more people
might be playing yeah I never got it
I've never been a huge kind of portable
game gamer I guess yeah yep yeah until
switch I guess but like I never owned
the last thing I owned was a PSP which
was like what a mistake yeah I know an
inch at all so come back to me boy days
yeah well okay so I I never had one but
uh I definitely played a bunch of like
oops I played a bunch of like Tetris on
my cousin's like Gameboy but that was
that was kind of about it I didn't own
one myself what else is coming out
battle for Azeroth expansion for Wow
yeah there's a bunch of Red Dead gonna
come out this year yeah April no Shelby
spring I think okay so my team has been
done for a while they just pushed it
back just to ma'am I don't know what my
theory is man what I said it a long time
ago I was like why would you come out in
2017 where there's such like so many
good quality but also rocks are they
value their reputation so they want to
get the Game of the Year awards
yeah exactly how they don't want to
compete with Zelda and and like Mario or
any number of games last year so many
good game guys hugged me for a lot of
people you know I was looking at giant
bombs list of ten recently and you know
they include a puppy we did not but I
was surprised to see a destiny in there
yeah I was actually kind of shocked Brad
really likes it right yeah I mean like I
know they raided together which might
have been the experience like I'm Alton
a to is kind of about you know how many
people you know that are playing the
game yeah because like to kind of keep
playing kind of I mean there's a
community built there but it's obviously
easier
have people to play with I just didn't I
was just shocked that they put it on
there yeah I think resi will to remake
will be officially and unveiled this
month for the anniversary 21st
anniversary I think so how they rumored
that at all yeah okay but I think
they'll actually unveil it they have to
and I think it would be this month if
anything all right I got a I got a I got
a keep looking for the exit get to mr.
Pablo me magnin Neiman apologies my
butchering that this is the darkening of
Tristram Diablo 1 anniversary event in
Diablo 3 there's 16 levels and I was you
be tell from the graphics kind of grow
back to for a Diablos anniversary yep
what so you see hablo what was 90 it's
january game of the year that year I'm
not mistaken it's Diablo 98 I'm not
mistake Oh yo look it up I want to see
this our game of the year right that
year I could be mistaking that one to
you but I'm pretty sure cuz I remember
it Richard just cut says damn it
December 31st okay uh but I believe we
gave that game of the year at least if
not game of the year game of the year it
was PC game of the year yeah I was 97
first 1996
yeah Richard just cut our like all our
game of the years over like till from
like our inception as GameSpot to in
2017 because last year was overwatch
well well last year now is Zelda yeah to
760 was overage 15 was Witcher 14 was
shadow of mordor 13 would have been link
between worlds right three of us mm-hmm
12 I don't know what 12 was what came
out that Dishonored XCOM enemy unknown
curious go look at stuff yeah trying to
think what's a secrete three came out a
year Borderlands 2 wasn't that if you
keep going I might be able to remember
oh yeah double make high five would be
pretty sick says that was medio e
that's a good shout did you see that did
you know that one like rumored like
reddit the leak thing were like they
were gonna show D mc5 at e3 but then
they ultimately decided to pull it so
it's probably gonna be this year cuz
like I think the creative director
something like that like he came out and
said like he's got something cool to
show
sorry for the delay kind of thing okay
the gallery is in reverse order so I'm
okay
it started with yeah Diablo in 96 yeah
that was just game of the year but yeah
between 98 and 2001 we gave a console
and PC game yep yeah I remember that
back when they were very separate things
some of these aren't really surprising
oh man 2006 is we'll talk about that not
really at the time I guess I don't know
9 you'd like two dozen nine I'd like two
thousand oh I don't know if he played it
actually I think well no there's a
reason I'm saying oh I think XCOM was
2012 I'm seeing the alien on the header
image yeah nice yeah alright so yeah 16
was over at wall 17 was Zelda 16 was
over watched 15 witcher 3 film 14 was
Middle Earth shadow of Mordor 13 was
Legend of Zelda link between worlds 12
Oh 2012 it's a journey oh okay he's calm
okay that doesn't 11 you could probably
guess what that was I'll just go five
I'm really this bad
I think I wasn't even in the voting for
that one I was I think my first year in
the vote disk alliterations was the
journey game and that seemed pretty
unanimous and so was linked to worlds it
was like shockingly like the one of the
least debated like things it was just
like a link between worlds and then like
you just see like a third like sorry
three quarters of the room just raise
their hand I was like okay that's
settled it was like what sorry 2010 was
Red Dead Redemption
yeah 2009 was Demon Souls that's when I
thought ooh
so John Luke really wants me to finish
my plate dude I made the first boss
which is apparently a lot easier than it
should have been for me I didn't die but
why did he come right in a son no I kind
of rushed the boss cos like we were kind
of getting to that 90 minute mark which
is roughly around how long we scream for
and I was like where's the boss he's
like oh you're close you're close you
know like get the shortcut and I was
like okay let's do it and do you
remember the first Demon Souls boss it's
like the guy with all the shields and
then he has like a bunch of like slime
Binion's and they like either attach or
you have to get anyways I didn't realize
for a longest time I've kept running
circles attacking it that like fire was
it's like biggest weakness yeah and so I
had to use like fire like the equivalent
to fire paper and then I was able to
like kill him oh cool and then everyone
in chat was like isn't this guy like
really easy I'm like oh [ __ ] I just
write captain kladdkaka was saying I
like how the animations feel more akin
to Diablo 2 but they kept the rag doll
house I just noticed that they yeah they
have some stuff in here that like they
were talking about like an ad like
previous quiz cons about how it was
actually really hard to kind of keep
some of the d3 stuff in here yeah but it
worked out I think it's cool I think
it's like I said I like to you know kind
of go through the event once get that
little nostalgic feeling that cool I got
my I got my itch you know she doesn't
hate was Metal Gear Solid 4 you know
into the Patriots 2007 Super Mario
Galaxy not really
oh I saw an ex-con because it was the
best messed up - best of 2012 okay
sorry 16x time - rightly so 2006 was
years of war so that was generous man
gave it a 9 and then I remember people
were pissed at me one of my earliest
reviews my works here was I gave gears
or Ultimate Edition a 7 so then they're
saying oh wow the same outlet gave the
same exact game which updated with
better graphics
- scores lower and then Jeff Gerstmann
came out with their score over at Giant
Bomb for the ultimate ition to give it a
6 out of 10
yeah three stars out of five I mean what
it was back then is that doesn't mean
that I cry flex now no but at the time
it was my innovative write it up in five
people can probably guess this resonable
for
2004 World of Warcraft makes sense that
was a thousand game changer winwaker
EverQuest had a warning when it was out
that whatever year it came out I don't
know do nothing - was Metroid Prime
I agree with my mic one of my college
buddies
EverQuest ruined - his one at least one
semester in school yeah I think he had a
zero point zero g k one semester how
like he got to a point where he knew he
was so far behind in class that he
stopped going to class and he just
played EverQuest sorry you said that was
what college college yeah he stopped
going to class in college and just
played EverQuest because he knew he was
so far behind that even if he had
started attending classes and doing like
tests and stuff like that that it
wouldn't matter and he wouldn't pass so
he was like spirit I'm just gonna play
EverQuest console was Grand Theft Auto 3
in 2001 PC was serious Sam first
encounter maybe at that time was really
cool I didn't play
mm was Chrono Cross that one was that
was the first freelance not attend was a
little hot second never freelance
connect 10 was this year divinity
original sin - I think the vanity had
deserved it more and then PC was the
Sims getting closer so we didn't start
doing this until 96 the first one was
Diablo 99 was Soul Calibur on console
and then yeah request on PC what do you
think Mike this way or that way bottom
last Bona one and swing circle what I'm
miss day 98 is probably obvious ocarina
on console pc was grim fandago yeah I
don't I've only ever
I finally played the game on ps4 two
years ago 97 was Total Annihilation yeah
that was an interesting one to Diablo 96
oh you're wrong like I think it's in the
oh you mean all the way down here or I'm
gonna try El Centro here yeah I don't
think this is it though
or do you think it just leads all the
way across the map it's looking that way
alright we're gonna check this bottom
corner we're close for more labyrinth
levels I think we can do it before in
the next 25 minutes yeah I think we can
I'm starting to speed through it and
I've got more ability I think so it'll
just be like it'll just be like a
plodding experience cuz he's gonna have
so much life I think it'll be fine
though we're only playing on hard no
it's a dead end should have finished
looking there first I guess because
there's nowhere else right yeah there's
nowhere else so you were mentioning that
Resident Evil 2 remake as high
possibility maybe not a high possibility
but I would think we probably time okay
are you guys gonna do that freaking evil
them
there you go um we haven't figured it
out yet a lot of people who watch
Knievel regularly arrest and we're gonna
do anything after a resonable seven
mm-hmm we would probably do Code
Veronica first and then resonable zero
and then like a B scenario over as equal
to or just do resident to remake that's
out by then are you gonna go through DLC
a resident so I think so they're easy
enough to there's short enough to get
through uh I don't know though they're
not that great well okay so I thought
101 was good like the birthday party yes
the tach was looking for yeah and the
the escape room with Marguerite but yeah
that one was crazy yeah that's crazy
puzzles I went to take a minute but also
the new ones the Chris Redfield one not
a hero and Zoey's end I did not like as
much Chris was better I think but Zoe's
end I could not really liked was the
Chris one the free one yes was the one
you're her uncle who lives nearby and
didn't find out about it yeah I was
watching those playing like you like
martial arts everything yep okay I got
lightning shock that's fine
still alive gonna watch it overwatch
League stuff oh yeah check it out a
little bit I don't know though for me
for some reason ever since I kind of
like they went to competitive even
though you don't have to play it
competitively it kind of I kind of
stopped I don't know became this thing
where I started getting rayji with it
like it felt like dota again to me where
I would spend you know 35 minutes to 40
minutes like playing it playing a match
and then losing and just feeling like
really yeah like upset
thanks Ichigo Kurosaki rip bleach that's
an anime what that guy's name Okazaki is
from a I'm informing wait uh also
Dragonball Fighters comes out soon as
you do right and in a month
oddly enough same day as Monster Hunter
world I'd rather play dragon ball
fighters first yeah it'll be a shorter
experience I think I'm gonna get through
that like fast and probably have fun
with it I mean the guilty gear I'm not
mistaken I'm I've been so wrong today
that I'm just noticed it's that same
like art axis systems
yeah the night's gonna he's gonna play
on ps4 tonight yeah console experience
is pretty good go like that you can
trade like that you can send items via
the mailbox to your buddy's like hey
Nina pick me up I got some Legendary's
that I use that I don't need anymore
would you like that twenty minutes and
Mike just tuned in on Twitch are there
any differences from last year's event
we do not believe so go kill her Michael
kill her just in case yeah nothing that
I've seen is different but it's all the
pet the cow and the butcher
maybe the portraits different I
unfortunately because I like kind of
already like it looks like your
skeletons are fighting each other
there bros man unfortunately since I
already like click through that like you
know how like when you start a game like
it'll show you like what's new in the
universe essentially I kind of already
clicked through that dark the darkening
of Tristram so I can't show the like
what's in it kind of thing I don't know
go back into it if you missed anything
if you didn't miss anything then I guess
it's not really too much for you to
aspire to achieve unless you just want
to play a missile throwback I want to
say like recently they did like they
read update it like a mod that was for
Diablo 2 that would be worth I missed
that game agar plate Ally that game to
you - yeah me too
yeah he told me he sold a lot of stuff
on eBay his brother
those duper's you'd have Pindell bot
you'd have like
did you ever bought in diablo school oh
man it was great like me and who they
used to do it he got is one of his
accounts banned because yeah because
it's like a script running your
character against like a certain enemy
type over and over it would make the
games and kill the boss and then leave
the game and make it like you know make
a new game yeah he got banned this is
kind of funny paradise the case of last
game they picked up in the steam chat
was cuphead nice solid choice sold over
2 million copies sad it didn't make our
top 10 list but definitely deserving to
be mentioned and also we did Joey did a
cool series with the developers and you
did - I think you helped as well so you
guys want to know more about cuphead
with the developers and how like the
dragon boss was made all right here we
go then go check that out yeah let's go
check that out it's on our youtubes also
under a spot that he's got to be down
here right so these are the cultists
they actually the cool thing is like
these guys they showed up before the
event started to kind of like hey
something's coming it's a very vile
thing to do which is cool though
destiny kind of did that a little bit
too we're like they would have like a
little mini event it's a kind of like
foreshadow like the coming of the big
events yeah come on where's this where's
the man here the Dark Lord is it right
oh yeah he's somewhere down here see up
there on the chip Chapel some painting
Oh
I don't wish they kind of redid the room
but I know they had to yeah the assets
of what's what are we missing here like
something we got an accident something
of that alter you gotta something ain't
right
a bad feeling about this Mike oh here
you go
Oh what the hell hey they trapped me in
a room hon outdoors over at least I
think we're gonna have to do the other
room - yeah probably this is kind of
like alright we killed it
that's not better than what I have it's
more damage a lot more damage alright so
do we think there's a book on the other
side you got it down there on the top
right gotta walk all the way over here
yep this is also the book of Lazarus
a little sketch poison probably doesn't
matter for in that girl at this point I
know if this little ever thought
Archbishop Lazar
yeah go go where my corpses are
oh damn he's taking a lot yeah which
makes me feel like the hablo himself is
gonna be a real pain the bud got time
yeah I got 15 minutes to kill him
Oh what did you he disappeared
dude just finish him off no he totally
disappeared oh he's bad it's killing
playing games he's definitely not the
Dark Lord this is annoying
Fight Like a Man the rush hour yeah she
said watch that alone
there's like that speculation that like
there's gonna be a four but I think in
every one of them has to agree oh we
gotta go to the Dark Portal alright can
we get any upgrades before we fight oh
yeah that's an upgrade for damage Oh
what oh because I don't have enough
inventory space that's fine we're going
glass cannon all right whatever I think
we're fine it'll be fine right Mike
wait what else did you check all that
other stuff down there oh oh this belt
better mmm-hmm I think it's fine no big
deal you know gloves yeah at level 25
I don't know we've been unlucky all
right we haven't found any hooks all
right
who goes there oh okay this is I did but
I don't remember it because this is very
like Diablo 1 a ski there was a lot of
rooms before you got to him and he was
like in the middle of a room when I did
it last year I did it on like an Opie
character so I kind of just wipe the
floor with everything yeah
whereas this might be exploded a more
true experience we're going through
doors Oh No
Oh buddy sorry there he is oh he's not
so bad Oh buddy got the lightning breath
uh-huh hey I've avoided some of it if I
would have hurt one oh he's got some
courses thank God for those ads come on
oh he's gonna spit it I'm gonna play
properly even though I don't think I
need to
yeah we did it ooh oh yeah yeah you get
the ending you get the education anyone
from doing this - yeah now GG ain't okay
so like he had to do this because if
anyone else got it they wouldn't be able
to like harness the evil yeah and yeah I
think you realize you you've come to
realize that that was just a like the
previous like warrior to I think like
that tried to carry the burden became
Diablo yeah I think it I think it just
becomes like a person with like a huge
yeah see yeah I tried to carry that
burden can do it turn up game sound
[Music]
shoves into his forehead
Oh
they make it oh yeah that's cool yeah
yeah yeah all right what did we get
what do we get Oh see so this is what I
was talking about let me pick up all
this other stuff while I'm at it in case
we ever need this this is that gem you
get and so like if I had a freaking item
that had a sock in it I think it has to
be the helm I can show it to my
permanent like if I I could show it to
you guys
periodically struggle for control like
to stun you or something
I think yeah you're stuck but then you
do like a huge AoE thing here let's try
to get a helmet with their sausage and
then I probably do actually that's a
good boy for a level 26 though I know I
don't because it's a new season so we'll
see if maybe the dude is selling
something oh no I just blew up the
butcher's cleaver whoops
whatever it became like a transmog she
can also get gloves oh yeah that's a
good call wait does that have a gym
that's right we can see if
what's-her-name can put it in there
the gym is really annoying oh really
does it have to be a house like that
good it has to be home I think a gem
just stuns you everyone's a while
doesn't it mantis Oh what have you a
level 12 I don't have enough money
maybe maybe what's her name selling one
hold on let's see the thief or whatever
there's a couple merchants yeah there's
a couple merchants I think yeah this is
back to d3 graphics we are no longer in
being about to the jewel you know he
would have said yeah give me the one all
the way over there I think this is a
venture mode you could go somewhere else
couldn't you what hope together hubs
yeah I could that does a good call
- I hate hate the little girl o karna I
hate it act to actually somebody sell me
a helmet with a socket oops said he saw
socking at one of those homes really
he's trolling I don't think I saw one oh
that one here we can just think you
gotta be struggle for control here let's
find out
you can open rifts now no problem and uh
like that not the greater risk with the
normal risks that was the thing they
changed because they didn't want people
to be upset about like farming tokens
hopefully I don't die in here it's gonna
be alright
oh the joke guys are really that's a
great thing right there no that was me
using bone armor
what's another like a 75% chance was it
on a hit just said periodically struggle
um doesn't have a chance all right
that's fine damage I'm sure it'll it'll
happen on its own at some point if
probably sucks from the standpoint that
like you can't if you can't control your
character then that Oh see here we go
you got stun boom look at that though
look how much damage it dude yeah it's
probably really good now but it probably
is not so great yeah that'd be annoying
but yeah because I couldn't do anything
it makes it stand there somatically lore
wise it makes sense but doesn't I'm
pretty sure Diablo could spam that crap
without having this oh so he wasn't
struggling oh you're still struggling to
remain good that's why okay yes so uh
alright I guess for prospective that's
fine alright what am I gonna do am I
gonna do normal outro on this huh yeah
normal shows fine let me you want to
finish this or should I just go back to
town thank you alright that's fair oh
it's gonna happen again one more time
that's all right cool thank you Mike for
this better be hardcore it was hardcore
yeah we lived no troubles we only played
on hard but if you guys want to check
this out the event is live across the
board run until 30th January 30th all
platforms yeah all platforms you don't
need a necro to play if you don't have
the necro pack if you want to just enjoy
it and get some of the stuff I think one
of them was let's see I think trans Ward
stuff oh [ __ ] has more it has to be an
axe I think yeah whatever
there's the butcher's cleaver I think
you can earn a pet which is god I forget
where the nope that's not it
god it's been so long Mike there's a
menu with all this stuff
oh is it in the closet now it's in the
closet isn't it have you seen this No
the closet the armory oh yeah yeah I
don't remember where the pets thing is
this is kind of silly
you don't remember either right oh it's
right here there so those are cool I
equip that uh let's see where's the
butcher's pet there it is
so you can earn this little guy I should
stop spinning him around I guess but
that's cool I don't know if I have the
is this the royal calf how do you get
all you don't know if I've gone on you I
don't know if that's the royal calf guy
maybe it it looks like it's a it's a cow
with a crown that which must not be
named you know so maybe it's that but
there's the butcher so yeah cool sorry
that took longer than normal but uh cool
we live again tomorrow hopefully this
computer will work hard you know yeah I
don't know yeah I did tell Sam that I
try to get her on a stream early in the
year I know she's familiar with the pub
jeez so I could potentially do that
maybe I'll have one of you guys stream
with her guys see you later thanks for
joining